to change and make up your mind is the
enemy of synthetic happiness and I'm
gonna show you why
Dilbert already knows of course you're
reading the cartoon as I'm talking
dogbert's tech-support how come eh I
abuse you my printer prints a blank page
after every document why would you
complain about getting free paper freeze
the other users giving my own paper egad
man look at the quality of the free
paper compared to your lousy
regular paper only fool or a liar would
say that they look the same now that you
mention it it does seem a little silkier
what are you doing I'm helping people
accept the things they cannot change
indeed the psychological immune system
works best when we are totally stuck
when we are trapped this is this is the
difference from dating in marriage right
I mean you go out on a date with a guy
and he picks his nose you don't go out
on another date you're married to a guy
and he picks his nose you know he has a
heart of gold don't touch the fruitcake
right you find a way to be happy with
what's happened now what I want to show
you is that people don't know this about
themselves and not knowing this can work
to our supreme disadvantage here's an
experiment we did it Harvard we created
a photography course a black-and-white
photography course and we allowed
students to come in and learn how to use
a darkroom so we gave them cameras they
went around campus they took 12 pictures
of their favorite professors in their
dorm room and their you know their dog
and all the other things they wanted to
have Harvard memories of they bring us
the camera we make up a contact sheet
they figure out which are the two best
pictures and we now spend six hours
teaching them about dark rooms and they
blow two of them up and they have two
gorgeous eight-by-ten glossies of
meaningful things to them and we say
which one would you like to give up I
have to give one up oh yes we need one
is evidence of the class project so you
have to give me one you have to make a
choice you get to keep one and I get to
keep one now there are two conditions in
this experiment in one case the students
are told but you know if you want to
change your mind I'll always have the
other one here and in the next four days
before I actually mail it to
headquarters I'd be glad to headquarters
I'll be glad to swap it out with you in
fact I'll come to your dorm room and
give just give me an email better yet
I'll check with you you ever want to
change your mind it's totally returnable
the other half of the students are told
exactly the opposite make your choice
and by the way the mail is going out
gosh in two minutes to England your
picture will be winging its way over the
Atlantic you will never see it again
now half of the students in each of
these conditions are asked to make
predictions about how much they're going
to come to
the picture that they keep in the
picture they leave behind other students
are just sent back to their little dorm
rooms and they are measured over the
next 6 to 3 to 6 days on their liking
satisfaction with the pictures and look
at what we find first of all here's what
students think is going to happen they
think they're gonna maybe come to like
the picture they chose a little more
than the one they left behind but these
are not statistically significant
differences it really it's this very
small increase and it doesn't much
matter whether they were in the
reversible or irreversible condition
wrong Oh bad simulators because here's
what's really happening both right
before the swap and five days later
people who are stuck with that picture
who have no choice who can never change
their mind liked it a lot and people who
are deliberating should I return it have
I gotten the right one maybe this isn't
the good one maybe I left the good one
have killed themselves they don't like
their picture and in fact even after the
opportunity to swap has expired they
still don't like their picture why
because the irreversible condition is
not conducive to the synthesis of
happiness so here's the final piece of
this experiment we bring in a whole new
group of naive Harvard students and we
say you know we're doing a photography
course and we can do it one of two ways
we could do it so that when you take the
two pictures you'd have four days to
change your mind oh we're doing another
course where you take the two pictures
and you make up your mind right away and
you can never change it which course
would you like to be in sixty-six
percent of the students two-thirds
prefer to be in the course where they
have the opportunity to change their
mind hello sixty-six percent of the
students choose to be in the course in
which they will ultimately be deeply
dissatisfied with the picture because
they do not know the conditions under
which synthetic happiness grows the Bard
said everything best of course and he's
making my point here but he's making it
hyperbolically it is nothing good or bad
but thinking makes it so
it's nice poetry but that can't exist
we be right is there really nothing good
or bad is it really the case that
gallbladder surgery and a trip to Paris
are just the same thing yeah there that
seems like a one-question IQ test
they can't be exactly the same in more
turgid pros but closer to the truth was
the father of modern capitalism Adam
Smith and he said this this is worth
contemplating the great source of both
the misery and disorders of human life
seems to arise from overrating the
difference between one permanent
situation and another some of these
situations may no doubt deserve to be
preferred to others but none of them can
be desert none of them can deserve to be
pursued with that passionate ardor which
drives us to violate the rules either of
prudence or of justice or to corrupt the
future tranquillity of our minds either
by shame from the remembrance of our own
folly or by remorse for the horror of
our own injustice in other words yes
some things are better than others we
should have preferences that lead us
into one future over another but when
those preferences drive us too hard and
too fast because we have overrated the
difference between these futures we are
at risk when our ambition is bounded it
leads us to work joyfully when our
ambition is unbounded it leads us to lie
to cheat to steal to hurt others to
sacrifice things of real value when our
fears are bounded we're prudent we're
cautious
we're thoughtful when our fears are
unbounded and overblown we're reckless
and we're cowardly the lesson I want to
leave you with from these data is that
our longings and our worries are both to
some degree overblown because we have
within us the capacity to manufacture
the very commodity we are constantly
chasing when we choose experience thank
you